[Applause]
happy
thursday everybody what a great show we
have tonight i almost don't want to
share it with you
so as you know wnba star brittany griner
is stuck in a moscow jail since february
for trying to walk through russian
customs with a vaping pen filled with
cannabis oil it's the most press the
wnba has ever got
over a traveling violation
[Laughter]
anyway
but really how stupid is she i mean who
tries to enter a foreign land with
illegal substances
you're gonna get me put on a no watch
list
it's true cat once left thailand with a
dozen ferrets
don't ask her how
but at least if you're gonna enter a
country with drugs be better at it maybe
spend a day or two at our border to see
how it's done
or call this guy for some advice
yeah
yeah you're clapping now you're clapping
now
besides isn't that why god made the
rectal cavity
it's how i bring a liter of soda from
home into the movie theater
not to brag
but it's obviously an absurd arrest and
grinder pleaded guilty of possession but
then she complained that she when she
was arrested the russian authorities
didn't read her her rights which is cute
that's like complaining that when you
ate at the olive garden the hostess
didn't tell you the chefs aren't from
italy
we're pretty much the only place who
reads you your rights brittany that's
one reason to stand for the national
anthem which britney doesn't
meanwhile canada flogs you for
mentioning rights and that's why i go
there twice a year
but now we learn the us has offered to
exchange prisoners in order to bring her
and an american marine paul wellin home
bride reportedly backs the deal so who
are we trading for well victor bout is a
russian arms dealer known as the
merchant of death whose weapons sales
fuel deadly global conflicts russian
officials have long wanted bout back
who's serving a 25-year sentence in the
u.s after convicted in 2011 of
conspiracy to kill americans deliver
anti-aircraft missiles and aiding a
terrorist organization he got another 25
for inspiring a nicholas cage movie
the prosecutors wanted life
silly's a tad more dangerous than
someone who shoots about 35 percent from
the three-point line
but now he could return to russia in
exchange for griner and the marine now
to some this trade seems more lopsided
than trey gowdy's haircut
and the
u.s state department is usually against
such trade since they incentivize
countries to detain americans and then
they use them as bargaining chips i mean
could you imagine if some country got a
hold of this guy
[Music]
this is why i rarely leave this country
or my home you know i once went to
jersey and i was held captive by the
governor in exchange for 25 women
without mustaches
a sexist would say
that is really terrible
but i realized that if i were to go
anywhere around the world i'd be seen as
a steal frankly i'm worth an entire
college football team
so like spirit airlines these trades can
be a threat to everyone traveling
according to our state department that's
a great joke but still
it seems heartless to leave two
americans languishing in moscow prisons
so what would you do
i believe it's time for
how do you complete a trade for a war
criminal when your brain is made of
spaghetti
he's the merchant of death and griner
plays for the wnba we went to wnba fans
for a comment
[Music]
[Applause]
that's not fair
i actually enjoy the wnba because it's
basketball without all that annoying
dunking
so is this the most unequal deal since
the colonists bought new york for some
seashells
they get an arms dealer back who has
vital info that putin can use and we get
an american who knows how to dribble
but do we need that we already have joe
biden
don't clap yet
[Applause]
and besides do we really need another
six-foot woman who spends her night
playing with orange balls
[Applause]
i told you not to clap that was just
disgusting
horrible oh my god people make me sick
but grinder's an american and so so is
waylon and ex-marine and shouldn't we
try to get them out but it's not that
easy victor sent weapons to numerous
west african conflicts he's buddies with
some very scary people who like gaddafi
and hezbollah and when it comes to
terrorism he's league mvp but then
there's that cynical voice in my head
that says aren't we all doing this game
of tit for tat the whole point of
grabbing a russian criminal is in case
russia grabs an american citizen two can
weaponize civilians when we capture
someone from another country he becomes
not just an inmate but valuable currency
unlike the dollar
so don't think of them as prisons think
of them as banks and then get creative
it doesn't even have to be prisoners
what if we made more trades in which we
threatened to send americans that we
don't want to foreign countries who
don't want them either
like what if we offered them the cast of
the view
you didn't hear the end of the deal
and in exchange we get this russian who
is truly talented
[Music]
i haven't seen a tongue move that fast
since superman mailed his christmas
cards
yeah see you thought it was going to be
disgusting
but it's a joke about licking stamps
i think
but think of the possibilities we could
trade michael avenatti jesse smellette
joy reid morning joe the whole cnn
primetime lineup every actor named ryan
i hate them
here's a few we could even give away for
free you know like the guy who had his
honeymoon in russia in fact we could do
our part to support russian communism by
sending all of these people
but in all seriousness oh
red meat
no need to clap
but in all seriousness it's gotta suck
to be the people who put in the hard
work to catch the merchant of death they
probably risk their lives but maybe if
the trade gets made they will get the
credit and they will get the thanks
because no one ever thinks of them when
the people finally come home bottom line
is americans must help americans even if
i said bad things about my country in
the past doesn't matter and i'd hope
that if i get arrested in some country
my president would do the same for me
although i doubt biden would free me
which is why we have to dump him before
i go on my european vacation
so when a bunch of law enforcement tie
me up and gag me it's because i paid
them
let's welcome
tonight's guests
oh my dad
his imdb page is taller than he is emmy
winning actor author singer and
instagram sensation mr leslie jordan
[Applause]
she talks so fast her sentences finish
with a sonic boom outnumbered co-host
emily cabano
[Applause]
the one time she served her community
was in an orange jumpsuit boxes
contributor cat tip
and he dropped a mic a week ago and it's
still falling right there my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champion tyrus
[Applause]
so leslie first off i have to say you're
my favorite leslie and my sister's name
is leslie
l-e-s-l-i-e yes
exactly what's your middle name alan
a-l-l-e-n my sister's middle name is
ellen stop you're still my favorite
leslie
that's going to make her cry oh i know
but we don't care do we no we don't give
it
no you can swear by the way have you
ever been detained anywhere
i've done some unfortunate
incarcerations you know i've been
yeah is that detained yeah
you were arrested
pretty much who was your cellmate
robert downey jr
especially i walked in and sat down and
there he was
and then years later i showed up and he
had forgotten i was on uh the alley
mcbeal show with everybody uh kalista
flockhart and ellen degeneres's wife
portia de rossi and lucy liu and all of
them and and robert walked in and and i
didn't he looked at me and said do i
know you
and i said to him zip it
i said we were in jail together and i
even remembered 152 pad a cell 13 top
bunk
wait you were on the top bunk
[Laughter]
actually he was top i was bottom
box
that was
cute literally that's what he was
talking about uh what were you in for
drunk driving oh okay several other
indiscretions i'd really rather not
discuss
do you think we should should we make
the trade
yeah but you got to even it out like
maybe vodka some furry hats
something
it's very uneven that's right we could
get a ton of vodka
i don't know what those hats are
actually made of though right yeah they
could be just cat probably i'll probably
cat they don't have a cat yeah speaking
of cat there's a cat over there
tyrus
people keep saying if we had paid these
athletes more in the wnba this wouldn't
happen what do you think of that
okay listen
sorry he's speechless
it's women's fault
okay you don't go support women
basketball
guys watch our basketball i go to guys
basketball game yeah so yell at each
other this isn't our problem if you
don't put asses in the seats you should
not get paid
how is it everyone else's fault it's
like me saying i had my own show outside
the building with no camera i'm like i'm
not getting any ratings it's not fair
guys
why aren't you guys watching me
because you have no camera not the point
you want to get paid more put the asses
in the seats yeah so look no more than
other women
no but they'll watch housewives throw
whine at each other it's 20 million of
them that's because they like they like
they like to fight they don't like the
teamwork we'll change add some hockey
rules to the wnba
should uh should we make the trade
yeah i think we have to because we're
already a week in administration and we
just the only thing that i'm worried
about
is
please don't send him first yeah
you know because you know they checked
the box not the resume of the negotiator
right so they're like we'll send them
there and they'll be so happy and
they'll send them right back and then
then we'll have to then we'll have to
make another trade yeah that's so yeah
we got to make sure that we don't got to
meet in a neutral
neutral place yeah like i don't know
like uh i don't know radisson
radisson in iowa
emily you're a lawyer although we have
no evidence of that
[Laughter]
take me as my world um do you what
happens when you get arrested in russia
i mean do you do you think she's going
through a hard time well i'm not a
russian attorney but uh
from what we understand um you know it's
not unexpected that she has absolutely
zero rights and zero of the privileges
frankly that we enjoy here in this
country because a lot of those rights
the way that they especially in this
administration are afforded us are
certainly more privileges than rights
i'll say this before i traveled to for
example malaysia my professors made us
watch return to paradise and they
remember that with vince vaughn and
joaquin phoenix and they were like this
is what happens if you are caught with
drugs in this country that we are about
to go to and so not one person did any
drugs in that country because we knew
that this sentence for such was the
death penalty at the time and so the
notion that there's anyone else to blame
or that should hold accountability for
not knowing the country's rules that you
are going to when you are an american
and therefore your right stop at your
border to me is only a measure of
disrespect for the country you're going
to and sheer ignorance and ignorance in
this situation is not bliss and the fact
that we are trading the merchant of
death to putin while he is still
actively invading ukraine to me biden's
the merchant of death like there should
have been there is not enough vodka in
the world to make this deal equal
although they can try it in my life at
least wow that's pretty pretty strong
you know i remember before we went
kayaking my dad had me watch deliverance
totally the same thing you're right
exactly emily you clearly did not see
deliverance
that is the worst happening what is the
worst father-son trip in the history
greatest
greatest probably one of the greatest
movies ever made all right cat
do you have any advice for brittany
next time she travels
i mean no
i'd say don't do that yeah
i don't know i mean i
i'm just excited because when i get home
i just got a really good idea what i'm
gonna ask my husband if i was locked up
in a rush in prison how long would you
wait for me and if he hesitates even for
a second i'll start a fight
i see all those tick tocks about like
red flags for toxic men and i'm like
that's i'm like that yeah um
but yeah i look i mean it's it's i think
it's obviously not just for her to you
know be spending any time
in a prison for drugs but i don't think
it's just when anybody does
exactly exactly but russia doesn't care
about your feelings no i i i don't ask
them to yeah that's good on you yeah we
also can't forget that there's another
person the marine and we got to think
about him and he's he's a marine i who
knows i don't know if he worked in the
cia but anyway he's we got to consider
him as well but that's the irony is that
this country imprisons people for
marijuana and yet they will trade the
merchant of death to get someone else
out from a foreign country's
imprisonment for the same thing that's
an amazing correlation and she goes to
russia a lot she's a star over there on
the russian women's basketball league
like so she knew it's not like she
didn't know it was arrogance like what
emily was saying so it's but we should
get her home because going to jail for
ten years yeah
did she have birth is ridiculous did she
even try to tell them it was nicotine
yeah i mean
but you know
russia does this a lot if you're in a
band they will lose your they will lose
your lose your instruments and then
it'll cost you a grand to find them that
happens when you go through customs all
right they're yelling at me we got to
move on because we have so much in this
show that is amazing mostly it's me but
it's okay about it they're pretty good
too hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else